[Musik]
geschichte präsentiert sich die
schweizer qualität überall auf der welt
roger federer ist der wohl berühmteste
schweizer weltweit nach ganz oben
geschafft hat es auch top model ronja
vor
eine der bekanntesten schweizer marken
trägt kalkilia in die welt hinaus
ihre geschichten sind schweizer
erfolgsgeschichten grenzenlos gut
am anfang waren an gelbe filzball und
ein tennisracket dass roger federer kaum
mehr aus der hand legen wollte seitdem
ist das ausnahmetalent auf erfolgstour
und bereits jetzt eine lebende legende
er ist ganz oben im tennis olymp
angekommen
unser king roger
[Musik]
[Applaus]
virtuosität und weltgewandtheit gepaart
mit coolness machen ihn zum vorzeige
schweizer
er lässt uns von einer perfekten welt
träumen wenn deutsche im rampenlicht
steht schaut die welt immer auch ein
wenig auf die schweiz
ja es ist der große stolz eigentlich
oder dass ich das dorf um die ganze welt
repräsentieren geben möglichkeit bekomme
jeder ganz ehrlich von thomas als
privileg und als glücksfall
also ich bin sehr sehr stolz schweizer
un-botschafter sie 310 wochen die
weltrangliste in den boden
20-mal grand-slam-gewinner er ist der
superstar und trotzdem typisch
schweizerisch bescheiden
das ist nur für uns beide wer ein
autogramm
wie viele leute auch mitten im hype
bleibt roger roger und ganz der
schweizer ich glaube hat mir ein boot
holte weil ich glaube wir sind
ich habe euch vor ich sie aber nicht
sofort müssen sich zuerst einmal
bewiesen oder ich glaube durch mein
erster junior open sieg wohl man andere
land wirklich sehr sexy war in allen
medien zunächst zu fuß ich werde ich
dort gesehen der schweizer oder aber das
ist einfach sofort wieder abgeflacht und
hat gesagt er sagt was nächste woche
wieder schauer und ich glaube das ist
hat denn eigentlich so wie in
vaterstetten sogar durch meine karriere
eigentlich minen ältere aber meine
familie meine freunde jeder im boden
oder hp ballon und das klappt vor allem
dass wenn ich am meisten praxen von der
schweiz das gefühl dass ich mehr besser
sich real beim sondern eher schlechter
und das mache ich immer wieder aufs neue
muss bewiesen mit 17 machte ihn der sieg
in wimbledon mit einem schlag zum
weltspiele mit 17 war habe auch noch
immer der baselbieter junge
[Applaus]
das tennis virus wurde schon früher
gesetzt geradlinig ging federer seinen
weg von der konsequenz her irgendwie
schweizerisch von der risikobereitschaft
her dann doch wieder nicht
[Musik]
was macht stellen also spielt tennis und
war später tennis und eine heiße ja
anscheinend nur tennis oder sorry dass
ich anders machen oder aber ich denke
mal ich probier's mal wenn es klappt
nicht so kennt da kann man vielleicht
abgesagt und zwei abschiede vor anderen
land so sagen aber groß träume und danke
alles ist möglich
aber jeder muss riechen oder und der
schweiz haben wir immer noch bei celle
pizzeria meinung anders seine
südafrikanische mutter lynette und vater
robert sie unterstützen den traum ihres
sohnes von anfang an auch mirka die frau
an seiner seite lässt den grenzen
sprengen als ehemalige profispielerin
ist sie für ihn partnerin auf augenhöhe
der federer klein macht für roger die
welt zur heimat und ist wichtiger teil
des erfolgsrezepts
[Musik]
wann immer möglich sind die kinder dabei
wenn ihr vater die tennis welt in atem
hält
applaus von henning ist den papa gedanke
war ach du und ich verdanke ich träume
sie kennt aber wenn ich sehe wie häufig
aber später in der nacht wenn sie
geschlossen manchmal schläft sogar und
jetzt heute ist natürlich möglichkeit
dass sie das selber am einzelnen
momentan geschehe aber wenn ich mal für
biomasse ihre kollegen trafen klub und
so weiter und damals das center for sind
und dass sie und das sind auch immer
länger durch die mautsätze natürlich
sehr gefreut
von solothurn nach new york der es hier
schafft schafft es überall dachte sich
auch ronja furrer von neun jahren zog
sie hierher
heute ist sie topmodel wichtigste
stadion
aber für mich sieht aber auch die oft
magath und ich muss auch immer leute
wenn der staat das ist für mich keine
andere stadt führte
ronja kommt aus vita kurven und war ein
mama ihr großvater schickte heimlich an
foto an einer modelagentur und legte
damit den grundstein einer unerhörten
karriere
diese brachte die schweiz reden an
sämtliche hotspots der fashionwelt ronja
ist unser topmodel heute steht ein
shooting an ganz unspektakulären drohen
ihr die u bahn
ronja models seit 13 jahren ein
fototermin und ein neues team bringen
sie längst nicht mehr aus der ruhe
seit ihrem vierten lebensjahr behauptet
sie sich in der kurzlebigen fashion welt
aber ich mache dich frisch
heute keine allüren hat ronja keine
haltung schon manchmal wird es auch ihr
zu viel und von dem er sich selbst
bleiben in einer welt die einen ständig
anders haben will
das scheint das geheimnis des schweizer
morgens zu sein
[Musik]
realistischer ist sich nicht zu glauben
oder für vorstellbar es ist nett roten
der limousine preise z
aber ihre kundenliste ist glamourös
chanel ralph lauren oder tommy hilfiger
woraus dann hast du hier nach paris
gehen
los angeles die aktion die kommt
irgendein verließ naja also wird es ein
anstrengender monat
[Musik]
meist kommen die aufträge kurzfristig
rein und werfen und private pläne über
den haufen
[Musik]
also ein muss mit einsamkeit kampf du
bist mehr forschen ja daheim du weißt
nicht was modisch der flexibus ivo jobs
kann sehr spontan ihnen durch
wahrscheinlich nicht bloß um ein
familientreffen und als miss absage wäre
der job
ronja furrer und roger federer
neben ihren initialen verbinden sie
tugenden die als typisch schweizerisch
gelten arbeit bodenständigkeit und
respekt
keine zwei stunden von mexiko city
entfernt lebt der schweizer karl p liga
mit von mexiko zählt der verein schaffen
durchbruch 2 ausgleich zur arbeit fahren
buch zu machen die bewegung sind auch
interaktiv sich ändern und das schön bin
froh wenn ich das wieder machen wollt
machen
[Musik]
schon als bub träumte charakter von der
großen weiten welt und ein schweizer
sackmesser
später zog es den manager nach
lateinamerika in mexiko steht er als
länderchef für das swiss army knife das
längst zur ikone geworden ist
vor 15 jahren oder südamerika sein
zuhause
der gebürtige ohne lebt seit seiner
scheidung alleine der schweiz bleibt er
treu
gesund ja ich finde das sogar im
internet zur box hammer trance radios
auf der schweiz und somit bin ich auch
für wohnen damit der schweizer weiß
immer was läuft und wenn dein kollegen
gesucht sind machen sie witze und sagen
du bist ja auch machen da ich sehr viel
mit und ich weiß was in die spitze auf
die viele jahre im ausland haben seinen
blick auf die heimat verändert wenn wir
im ausland läuft dann so werde man fast
ein besseres wilma kürten schweizers
läuft und die probleme musste geht und
ich spüre das sind gar nicht problem
wenn ich sehe was da zum teil ablauf der
politik kredite jährig und das wird sich
das den vierfachen immer so ein flugzeug
das sehe ich jetzt das
tatsächlich kein fordert und ich lebe
das land ich lebe die lüfter bisherigen
die erwartungen an karl thier liga sind
hoch mit seinem team soll er in diesem
jahr für ein wachstum von zehn prozent
sorgen
das sind die erwartungen des
mutterhauses in ibach luchse generation
etwas verpflichtet und 21 gestellt dafür
verantwortlich dass titel nennt das
risiko meint dass man auf vorwärts
bringen und das klima für seine firma
der richtige am richtigen ort es zeigt
er mit einer neuen kollektion
ich bin neugierig zu sehen wo wir jetzt
stehen wir arbeiten mit indigenen
kunsthandwerkern zusammen das sind die
ersten muster das ist das typische
mexikanisches design mexiko sehr schön
gefällt mir ich werde dieses muster in
der schweiz mit victorinox anschauen und
diskutieren
[Musik]
erfolgreich werden ist das eine
erfolgreich bleiben das andere zuhause
in manhattan arbeitet ronja an ihrem
digitalen auftritt der immer wichtiger
wird
ihr seid das französische vogue als vor
der wichtigste magazin ist so wie er die
alte etwas so musste sie hat es
geschafft aber die ersten gehversuche
waren hart 14 erich in paris az 34 euro
das aks annika und mich seit heute das
ab der welt warten am bahnhof und dass
ich mir immer taxi und nach einer ecke
indien im namen und damit das shooting
fahrer oder zum ausklang das ist
shooting ich was jetzt passiert was ich
muss machen und das ist wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
von elke vogel ersten mal
[Applaus]
ronja hat sich mit anstand nach oben
gekämpft schlagzeilen über party exzesse
oder drogen machte die schweizerin nie
die bodenhaftung habe sie nie verloren
das weiße gold und überschreite
[Musik]
aber auch sie hatte krisen ein
bandscheibenvorfall brachte die
27-jährige an ihre grenzen
seitdem achtet sie noch mehr auf ihre
gesundheit und auf mentale stärke
deshalb hat sie mit boxen angefangen
das helfe
es macht einfach mehr spaß
bin ich immer noch so stein
ach du bist gut sagt mir ruhig du bist
du ich bin zu meinem job
man nennt das model nacken darum sagt
felix
das business ist hard for fashion shows
muss ronja fast so intensiv trainieren
wie eine spitzensportlerin für das
design
also schön außer meinem vorbereite und
fassen das ist mit verlaub ich mit ganze
programm an das muster und diszipliniert
[Musik]
ronja eine moderne version der
räubertochter so scheint es mutig und
selbstbestimmt aber da sind auch andere
momente dann vermisst sie die familie
und ihren liebsten den musiker andres
andrekson bekannt als stress in
versöhnter sie wenn man gern möchte aber
ich glaube mich sie weil die tritte so
schwer weil ich selbst ich strebe die
matches realistisch ist hingegen in und
mehr unterstützen wie somit finden immer
der vag dass man israel und das stimmt
aber dass
[Musik]
zwei stunden fährt kalk liga mit seiner
mitarbeiterin nach pachuca dort lebt
einer der berühmtesten köche des landes
der sich für sie zeit nimmt
ok service ist der star unter den
mexikanischen chefs die produktion guten
tag hier machen wir als busen
das ist unser preis küche und restaurant
küche und hier haben wir eine zunge
[Musik]
achilles und sein team entwickeln die
traditionelle küche mexikos weiter
immer schon habe er gerne mit den
messern aus ibach gearbeitet sagt jarvis
der koch ist influenza für victorinox
seine videos gehen wir an die qualität
der videos ist sehr gut
[Musik]
sie sind vielleicht nicht gerade
künstlerisch aber sie sind einzigartig
doch man kann es künstlerisch nennen
jazz wie die gourmets köche die die
küche weiterbringen haben viel an
bedeutung gewonnen
der 42-jährige spitzenkoch hat sich auch
in der schweiz weiter gebildet
das war fast militärisch in der schweiz
vor allem die pünktlichkeit keine minute
später alles muss ganz pünktlich sein
schweizer zeit
ich glaube eure fröhlichkeit das
spektakel und wir schweizer
das ist eine sehr gute kombination
mexikanischer enthusiasmus oder
schweizer geschäft sehen
das klingt nach einer win win situation
ciao
[Musik]
jeden zweiten donnerstag abend hat der
46 jährige schweizer ein review
[Musik]
guten abend können sie ein auge auf das
weiße auto haben
danke die deutschschweizer community von
puebla trifft sich zum traditionellen
jazz abend in mexiko ist manch ein
schweizer reich geworden auch
erfolgreichen die meisten hier sind
geschäftsleute und die tradition
tradition sei man damit auch mein essen
pflegt man traditionen als vorspiel für
mini kollege die die wenn die motionärin
tourismus platter mache das rezept von
monatlich auf user und der anteil sogar
bei eigener verweigerung
wie zu hause und doch gibt es auch
deutliche unterschiede
alles in ordnung die lampe und die
pfeife
nachbar ist und wir sind nur wie viel
land heißt das wenn der alarm machen
müssen dass es los ist einmal als hans
gerade die löhne ausbezahlt wurde er
überfallen
huber weg noch drin natürlich galt ganz
geldwechsel bitte mal mit einfach immer
aufpassen und darf frauen immer noch als
reiner ein überwacht mit dem die
schweizer die sich die heimat nach
mexiko geholt haben gelten als reich
zuverlässig und pünktlich
das würde das geschäft aber wenn man
sieht was hier läuft diese behörde oder
die politik und dann gesehen hat weiß
nicht wie's läuft das alles kalt
was kann die bürokratie alles leistung
wenn der news wie ist machen sie schnell
zu dass auch ein und hier ist das zum
teil ja schwierig wenn der polizeihund
den band überhaupt nützlich oder zu mir
exportwerte wurden und schließt erklärt
worden oder unfall gemacht haben das war
die zeit einfach die legal bewaffneter
krimineller und dennoch ist mexiko ihr
zuhause geworden
kaum einer denkt an eine rückkehr in die
schweiz
[Musik]
roger federer und seine fans das ist ein
regelrechter liebesgeschichte wo immer
er hinkommt löst der einen rummel aus
dem der schweizer mit bescheidenheit und
freundlichkeit begegnet
anstehen den zaun stehen lassen
für diese norbert heute verehren ihn die
fans oft mit bedingungsloser ergebenheit
wie die australierin helen ich folge ihm
überall in australien ich stehe um ein
zwei oder drei uhr nachts auf wo immer
er spielt in europa ich war fast keinen
match in dem baby habe ich ihn dreimal
gesehen ich war fünf mal in der schweiz
übernachtete in einer jugendherberge mit
blick auf sein haus er ist wunderschön
bescheiden großartig es ist sehr
anstrengend demnach zu reisen wenn er
verliert spreche ich drei tage lang mit
niemandem in meinem nach mit habe ich
geschrieben helens größte liebe war
federer dann die familie
ich liebe roger federer
ich weine ich bin verrückt aber so ist
das eben
und obwohl die fans es nicht gerne hören
der 38-jährige hat pläne für ein leben
nach dem tennis zirkus
ich fühle mich sehr wohl auf gewalt
wichtig ist aber dass man ja immer mehr
gesprochen
nein immerwährend anstoßen und anwohner
und da das dortmunder eine kurze frei zu
leben trotz prominenz ein privileg dass
die schweiz möglich macht
die weit von der schweiz vor respekt und
vor
meine frau sehr viel glück reden
eigentlich wie schön unser land ist wie
sich das land ist es funktioniert die
scheibe im kindergarten auf
verschiedenen ebenen land tauschen
entschuldigung bei der fahrer wenig
ergaben dass wahrscheinlich überall
haben wir extrem viel luxus von
parasiten oder dass man die freiheit der
hand eigentlich in unserem land und der
respekt vor mir euch uns gegeneinander
gab die fahrradfahrer etwas mit dem
event irgendwie stören dass man immer
führend erstmal vor wie oder und ich
glaube das ist für uns sehr willkommen
und ich war seine mit sehr viel glück
über das rederecht in die welt
hinausgehen und sie suchen was einem
fehlt und dann nach hause zurückkehren
um es zu finden
vielleicht ist auch das ein schweizer
charakterzug
[Musik]
was ist typisch schweizer schwer zu
erklären aber bald in der schweiz hat
das gefühl ist ein richtiger schweizer
[Applaus]
[Musik]
er hat eine sehr sehr sagt der
nationalhymne geschenk das wir nicht
häufiger passiert aber das gefühl von
daheim und der forderung sehr viele
schweizer fahnen und schweizer die
zeigen sich habe und wie viel meter
unheimlich stolz auf das höchste
schweizer sowieso
[Musik]
es sind sie da
[Applaus]
roger federer ließ sich nicht aufhalten
und hielt an seiner vision fest sehr
wichtig ist einfach dass man der
sportler hilft träumen oder mädels gab
im sport ist ganz wichtig dass man dabei
hat das verschaffe und nicht nur auf den
bestwert in rom basel und der beispiel
in der schweiz rund 40 als der vater von
der wald für die geschichtsbücher
[Musik]
ich sehe
[Applaus]
[Musik]
auf der wenig
das war den damen und herren ist der
vertrieb lobte wahnsinn
[Applaus]
[Musik]
karl chilliger ist im kanton uri
aufgewachsen
regelmäßig zieht es ihn in die heimat
zurück schwitzt oder zwar die bar
gesehen dass heime darauf eine ende der
kindheit gott im moment mit kollegen mit
der familie und das macht ihm spaß hier
in ibach hatte früher gearbeitet
das familienunternehmen victorinox wird
für seine innovationskraft und sein
nachhaltiges management regelmäßig
ausgezeichnet karl elsener der ceo und
urenkel des gründers nimmt sich zeit für
seinen mann in mexiko mit typischer
mexikanische designs und ich danke
dominierend sind in mexiko mehr salär
bedauert und axicom josef reiter wenn
sie ihre wo studieren kulturen vom ruf
meiner schützen und was sind die
sackmesser aus ibach sind weltweit
bekannt und sogar darüber hinaus
christin kanadische astronaut und hat
über 40 stunden im weltraum verbracht
habe ich in der später trug sich an die
russische raumstation mir autocross in
den achtzigern zum glück aufs tor und
hätte das gemachten technik können luft
und ttc spieler zurückgeholt und dessen
co-star in dem buch schreibt sowie die
tattoos piercing hinter mir using the
swiss army knife und der nachsatz von
derzeit never leave the planet worden
und doch hebt man hier nicht ab und
feilt weiter an den produkten
[Musik]
mit seiner früheren arbeitskollegin
begutachtet kalk jähriger die
verbesserten prototypen
sind sind gerade alle wild großes
dankeschön ja ganz schön ist daher immer
funktioniert haben wir sind auch die
heimatverbundenheit gepaart mit
weltoffenheit rahmen karl geholfen
seinen traum zu verwirklichen
[Musik]
weit weg von new york in lütter kufen im
kanton solothurn
hier ist ronja fores wohlfühlort
aufgehoben
in der patchwork familie ihre eltern
familie möchte der familie die eltern
brachten ronja stets viel vertrauen
entgegen
aber als die 14-jährige
mutterseelenallein nach paris reiste war
auch dem vater mulmig zumute
[Musik]
die mutter dagegen glaubte immer daran
dass alles gut kommt so oder so sie wie
sich das wichtigste das sägewerk und
dreifach pause drehten wir entstanden
jetzt so schön so schön einfach läuft
familienmensch ronja 50 hier geborgen
und aufgehoben vielleicht haben sie
diese starken wurzeln nie stolpern
lassen
in solchen momenten ist das andere
zuhause in new york ganz weit weg
nächste station respektive und gefragt
haben muss jetzt freitag auf new yorks
seite durchaus schon einmal aktiv werden
auch neo zurück aber das sieht eine 20
stunden reichte das tor das melatonin
die natur gibt ihr ebenfalls halt und
alkane dem der user nimmt
beim ausritt mit der schwester schmiedet
ronja auch schon mal zukunftspläne
vielleicht machen die im sozialen
bereich bei denen aber jetzt momentan
ich meine konzentration auf dem model
ist diese verwöhnte der schweiz das ist
so hoch dass schweizer schönsten darum
glaube ich schon dass es nie wieder zu
sehen
[Musik]
mehr erfolgsgeschichten in einer woche
philomena schwab ist die überfliegerin
in der schweizer gamer szene dem silicon
valley gibt sie einen korb denn sie
träumt von einem silicon valley in
zürich
[Applaus]
carlos marbach ist profi keser aus
leidenschaft mit schweizerischer
exzellenz coach der unternehmer in der
mongolei der ehemalige profi biker
claudio caluori baut heute pump trucks
in der ganzen welt und macht kindern
hoffnung auf eine bessere zukunft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
schweizer erfolgsgeschichte ist
präsentiert wurde von swiss ich die
schweizer qualität überall auf der welt